You might think this is Austria, or Switzerland but what if I told you this is Italy?
But… listen carefully.
You’d expect for the people there to be
speaking Italian, right?
Well, in this case you’d be wrong.
The main spoken language here is…
GERMAN!
Of course, this is South Tyrol.
Yes, South Tyrol is in Italy, but they speak
German.
In fact, we think Italian is the main language
spoken in Italy but… nope.
Italy is full of dialects and languages that
are hardly understandable from one another.
Somebody from Veneto, in the North, could
hardly understand somebody from Sicily, in
the South.
Yes…
Italy is a country of contrasts…
And the same goes for their politics.
Could you imagine a hard right party making
a coalition with a liberal populist one?
Could you imagine a Trump-like republican
making a coalition with someone who advocates
for a basic income for the poor?
Well… this is pretty much what they have
in Italy.
So how is that possible that right and left
can join forces to govern a country?
How is this possible?
In this video, we tell you the story…
Italy is a country of contradictions.
In one hand, it is the country where the Vatican
is: a country that maintains the respect for
their catholic traditions.
But on the other hand, they had Silvio Berlusconi,
a man famous for his orgies, as the prime
minister for years.
On one hand, they are one of the most over
regulated countries from all across Europe,
with red tape all over the place.
On the other hand, black economy here is bigger
than anywhere else.
If this doesn’t sound like enough contradiction
to you, then check this out: Italy’s government
is now a coalition of a far right wing party
and… a far left wing one.
OK, is true, the 5 Star Movement is not exactly
a far left political party… at least, not
in the sense that Occasio Cortez would be.
But… how do you call a party that advocates
for things like a basic income for the poor
or… reducing the salary of the politicians
so they can look more like the working class?
Definitely, within the parliament, 5 stars
movement is as left as you can get in Italy,
excluding the communist that have little influence
in politics.
And how about the far right wing?
The LEGA party is… also a contradiction
in itself.
Now they appear as an anti immigration, nationalist
party that claims the Italian first motto.
But they were born as a secessionist movement!
In fact, originally, LEGA was cold LEGA NORD,
which means the Northern League.
And they wanted Italy to be splitted in two
different countries.
Now… they have changed their minds and appear
as the paragon of Italian pride.
But hold on just a second… now you might
wonder…
Why do we care about this?
Well, first of all, its size.
Italy is the third biggest economy in the
Eurozone and they have the worst recession.
If they fall, Europe might fall too.
And, if Europe falls, the rest of the world
might fall, too.
But also, the case of a coalition of opposite
extremes can help as a cautionary tale for
many other countries.
So yes, you want to know more about Italy.
So now the question is… how is that possible
that right and left could merge together?
Can this strange formula succeed in order
to bring the country out of the collapse?
Well, today we are going to answer to all
of this questions but, before we do, let’s
take a look back at the history.
FROM LEGA NORD TO, JUST, LEGA
As we said before, there are, approximately,
34 spoken languages and dialects in Italy.
But the differences don’t stop here.
You can also tell them… when it comes to
economics.
Southern Italy has a unemployment rate close
to 20%.
In places like Sicily, water shortcuts were
a common thing until recently.
And most of the people work on the agriculture…
But, oh boy, Northern Italy is a totally different
country.
This is the country were brands like Ferrari
or Lamborghini were born.
Cities like Milano are worldwide famous for
their fashion industry, their factories and
their high standards of living.
Their unemployment rate is just a third of
that of the South.
And their income doubles that of the southerners.
This big divide is what explains the birth
of the NORTHERN LEAGUE party in the 90s.
As I’ve said at the beginning of the video,
the party was founded as a regionalist secessionist
movement.
The forerunner was Umberto Bossi.
Originally, he just wanted his own region,
Lombardy, where Milano is, to become independent
from Italy.
But then , one day he thought “why not unify
several northern regionalist movements in
one?”
. This is how the biggest separatist movement
in Italy was born.
Originally, it was not meant to be a right
or a left wing party.
In fact, many of his founders came from anywhere
in the political spectrum.
They had just one goal and one goal only:
split Italy in two halves.
Basically, the country they want to create
was called PADANIA and it comprised all the
Northern Italian regions.
As any other separatist movement, they claimed
several cultural differences.
But, unlike the Scottish separatism, the main
reason for this self determination movement
was… money!
Basically, BOSSI claimed that Rome was stealing
the money from the richer regions to give
it to the poor.
So they would be better off going their own
way.
And believe me, when it comes to hating Italy,
he was pretty straight ahead.
“When I see the Italian flag, I feel like
shitting.
I use the green, white and read to clean my
ass” –Umberto Bossi
Bossi went as far as declaring Padania independent
from Italy in 1996.
But, look, as separatists as they might be,
this Northern League was still an Italian
party.
This means they had to play by the Italian
rules and run for the Italian parliament.
And, in order to expand their national influence,
they became one of the most loyal allies of
Berlusconi.
This helped them to get very good results
because their voters could see that, despite
being a regional party, Northern League had
enough power to influence politics and bring
lots of perks to the regions they represented.
“Wake up, Padania!
With the Northern League, against the thieves
of Rome”
But as influential as they could be, they
could only get as much as 8.3% of the votes.
This means, it was still a small political
party…
But thing changed in 2012.
That was the year when Umberto Bossi suffered
a stroke and… he had to leave the party.
His successor was this man you see on the
screen: MATEO SALVINI.
And he had a radical change in mind for the
party.
First of all, he changed the name.
So it went from Northern League to just…
League.
And that kind of rebranding means one thing:
the party was evolving.
The electoral program was not focused on the
dominance of the North over the South anymore.
Finally, the enemy was not Rome anymore but…
THE IMMIGRANTS!
“More immigrants mean more criminals.”
Salvini is working on a repatriation plan.
And what happened to that anti Italian feeling?
Aren’t they the biggest enemy of Padanians
anymore?
Well… if you think a party cannot change
its mind from one day to the other… think
twice…
‘Raise your head, Italy!
I’m proud of being Italian.
We are the best country in the World, we just
need a little bit of work and a little less
taxes’ Matteo Salvini
Boom!
There you go!
Now the former Northern League can apply to
all the Italian voters, both Southern and
Northern.
This means a bigger voting market and better
results.
And I know what you might thing… can anybody
take seriously a party who can change their
core ideology from one day to the other?
The answer is…
YES
Lega Victory at Italian elections, times are
a-changing
But if this doesn’t seem crazy enought to
you, let’s see the other player on this
game: the Italian populist left.
Let’s have a look at it!
THE BIG JOKE
It’s the year 2009 and Italy is dealing
with a big crisis.
The European Union wants budget cuts, and
Berlusconi and his government are in dire
straits.
That’s the fertile ground on which the FIVE
STARS MOVEMENT was founded.
During those years a famous comedian, Beppe
Grillo, started a platform.
He had little to no idea on how big his blog
and movement were about to become.
Perhaps the most interesting moment of the
movement’s developing phase was the 2007
Vaffanculo day in Bologna.
Literally, that meant the ‘FUCK OFF day’.
It was a huge event meant to collect signatures
to change the then electoral law.
They wanted to avoid people convicted of crimes
to run for parliamentary elections.
But the real opportunity for Beppe Grillo
came some years later.
The Italian economy was still struggling.
More and more citizens couldn’t make ends
meet.
And this is when Italy gets a fully technocratic
president: Mario Monti.
A technocrat is somebody who claims not to
have any ideology whatsoever: just tries to
solve problems and manage politics on the
most effective way.
But to many Italians, this seemed to be an
imposition from the European Union, who wanted
more and more budget cuts and more austerity.
So this anger is what gave momentum to Beppe
Grillo and his Five Start Movement.
The Movement started winning and placing its
members in regional and local cabinets.
This momentum gave them the chance to run
in the 2013 general election where they were
the second most voted party after the Democratic
Party, defeating everyone’s expectations.
They gained more than 8 million votes.
Which is a pretty huge number for a brand-new
party.
The election’s results are in: huge victory
for the 5 Stars Movement.
The web’s euphoria for the first party in
the Chamber of Deputies.
The movement started as an anti-establishment
force and therefore at the beginning it didn’t
seem to have a very detail-oriented plan.
But all their work paid off and all those
voters gave them the push they needed.
It was time for a detailed plan.
It was time to become more structured.
And then it came a big win: in 2016 Virginia
Raggi becomes Rome’s Mayor.
The 5 Stars Movement conquers Rome: Raggi
elected mayor with 67% of the votes.
“It’s an historic moment, the Roman citizens
have won”
Their first huge win meant even more wind
under the movement’s wings.
The movement’s ideology became clearer:
direct democracy as an evolution of representative
democracy.
The idea that the citizens will no longer
delegate their power to parties was at the
base of Rousseau, an online voting platform.
Through Rousseau the registered users of M5S
discuss, approve or reject legislative proposals.
For example, the choice to support the abolition
of a law against immigrants was taken online
by the movement’s members, even if the final
decision was against Grillo’s own opinion.
Grillo, the M5S registered voters say no to
making illegal immigration a criminal offence.
Another chapter of the party’s life began
when Luigi Di Maio came into power in 2017.
And in 2018 he became Deputy Prime Minister
of Italy and Minister of Economic Development,
Labour and Social Policies.
The improbable ascent of the 31-year-old college
dropout and former soccer stadium usher is
really a measure of the country’s turbulent
political landscape.
And so, on one hand we have a seasoned right-wing
politician and on the other we have a 31-year-old
freshman.
And they were tied together in an unlikely
marriage by the 2018 election.
OPEN MARRIAGE
Italy is infamous for having weaker than usual
political alliances and parties.
Since the country was proclaimed a republic
in 1946 it has had 29 Prime Ministers with
an average government length of 2.5 years.
Every election is a brand-new start for everyone.
The last big change came in 2018, when a new
government was established after a very complicated
post-election period.
The new government is an alliance, as we said,
between the anti-establishment Five Star Movement
and the far-right League.
The populist wave split Italy in half: the
South voted for the 5 Star Movement and the
North voted for the Lega, but both sides expressed
a vote of protest against more traditional
parties like the Democratic Party.
This new numbers show a real shift in Italy’s
electoral geography.
The success of the two most anti-establishment
forces is mostly due to economic uncertainty.
The outsiders have become the mainstream.
Immediately after the elections, the 5 Star
Movement, the party that got the most votes
needed to find a coalition party.
The choice was the Lega.
Italy election: Populist Five Star and League
vie for power
But this marriage wasn’t an easy one, it
took 10 weeks to reach an agreement.
The two parties were adversaries before the
election.
But at the same time, they became the largest
groups able to muster a majority in both houses.
And so, the 5 Star brought to the table their
32% and the League its 17% and the new government
began.
We’re now a few months in and the two deputy
Prime Ministers, Salvini and Di Maio are doing
the most to fulfill the promises they made
to their voters.
Salvini is trying to crack down on immigration
and to pass a flat tax rate of 15% for companies
and individuals, which experts say it would
cut tax revenues by 80 billion Euros per Year.
Di Maio is trying to make a huge basic income
reform happen.
It’s a universal income for the poor that
would cost an estimated 17 billion Euros per
year.
The two leaders are basically in an open marriage:
they’re together but they’re still looking
around for partners.
Both parties are staying together, but they
are still trying to get the biggest political
capital possible for the next election cycle.
But pleasing an electorate is in itself a
very difficult feat to accomplish, even without
further obstacles.
La dolce vita slips away again as Italy tumbles
back into recession
The country is now in a recession, just as
the Italian Deputy Prime Ministers stated
that Italy was on the cusp of an economic
miracle.
In 2018 the GDP decreased 0.2%.
This is the third recession in 10 years, but
the Italian PM says not to worry.
He stated that a recession is “determined
by the European economic cycle” whatever
that means…
While politicians are playing the “blame
it on the people who were here before” card,
many Italians are extremely worried on how
this recession could have an impact on their
lives for years to come.
Italy has the second largest debt after Greece,
but its economy is eight times larger and
a crisis this big could severely cripple the
Eurozone.
So now the question is, is it possible to
see a similar alliance in other countries?
Can this alliance save the country from further
crisis or is it going to make things for worse?
Please, leave your answer on the comment section
below.
And of course, don’t forget to visit our
friends from RECONSIDER MEDIA.Com, the podcast
that provided the voices on this video that
are not mine.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and as always, I’ll see you next time!